yeah pretty sure i made a catch on one
or two of them and a tent revival about
a month ago speaking of nice catching
out there today catcher i was out of
position you were out of position took
that guy in our day at the ground I was
right no you weren't I was surprised
when a good hot dogs or I'm s hey Bob
good of you to come drumming up business
for the show thank you you're welcome
listen uh I don't think I can do the
more I I need my privacy I I come home
got over 300 emails plus I got the God
Squad camped out on my front yard i
can't i'm tired all right you're just
growing pains jack it's nothing to worry
about so i'll probably master plan
others plan that's comforting there's
something happening here who are you
okay well she's right jack I mean look I
don't think you raised that weird guy
from the dead or nothing but I seen him
out on the road here he is affecting
people you are Jack whether you like it
or not all I'm saying is that Jack just
looked at me and then that's all it took
quit staring at me dudes am i right now
I mean it's bad enough I gotta put up
with the unwashed masses thinking I'm in
second coming now I got to hear it from
you guys